joining me now from Exeter is the
founder and chairman of the JD
Wetherspoon pub chain and prominent for
Exeter Tim Martin he thinks he's
concerns are more smoke than substance
Tim very good evening to you nice to see
you there so um you think the reason may
really has nothing to worry about at all
here well I'm I think I am worried that
she's giving away too much and that
there's been a lot of misleading
information about the absolute necessity
for a deal for example that food prices
will rise that's come from big business
and it's not true if we leave the EU in
March 2019 we can reduce food prices for
everyone in the country and save 200
million pounds a week
so what Theresa May is doing has to be
balanced against that and it seems to me
reminiscent of desperation to do a deal
at any cost and it's definitely not
worth it why are you so convinced though
Tim that price at food prices and drink
prices will fall if we revert to WTO
rules I mean that's not for example what
the Institute of Fiscal Studies which
isn't you know an unimpeachable
impartial organisation that's not what
they say it's very it's it's very
surprising the British Retail Consortium
has said that food prices will go up the
chairman of Sainsbury's has said it what
actually is true is that the EU charges
tariffs to non EU countries when we
leave the EU if we leave in March 2019
Parliament has the power to eliminate
those tariffs if it does that under
World Trade Organization rules which
it's entitled to do it automatically
means there are no terrorists from the
EU now somehow the guise that these
organizations haven't said that or
haven't wanted to say it and it's given
the message to the British public and to
mp's that food prices are going to rise
now that's if the reverse is true and it
is true everyone needs to reconsider
food prices going down you've been
talking about poverty today and saving
200 million pounds a week 200 million
pounds a week is enough to give the
700,000 people you're going to be
talking about later in your program who
have are beneath the poverty line 15,000
pounds per annum each not that people
would do that but these are the vast
sums of money we're talking about
there's been a lot of spin from people
with probably just a religious zeal for
the EU and they've misled the public I'm
sorry to say yeah but Tim Italy at the
case I mean the fact that the pound has
fallen so much against both the dollar
and the euro since the referendum means
that any gains that one might see from
leaving the EU in terms of terrace
coming down as you suggest are
completely negated by the weakness in
sterling I don't think that's through
the the the the pounds been up and down
over the years since we've been in the
EU and everyone almost every economist
said it was too high
immediately before the referendum there
was a bit of a correction it's gone back
up since stock markets had a record
level Weatherspoon prices have hardly
moved Aldi and Lidl prices are
incredibly competitive it's all a bit of
a shaggy dog story whether Springs
prices might not have moved but I mean
that's eating into your margins because
you have to take that hit don't you well
we had record profits last year we're
doing pretty well the fact is that the
pound goes up and down it always has
done the public knows this it's not
axiomatic that if you stay in the EU
you've got a high currency and a high
currency is exactly what has stuffed
Greece Spain etc which have had to live
with the euro so the automatic
stabilizer of the currency is working
very well in the UK
and we've nothing to worry about with a
floating pound but tariffs definitely
create higher food prices so whatever
the food prices are now they'll be lower
if we leave the EU and Parliament votes
to eliminate tariffs which is what it
actually should do right okay Tim well I
hope you'll you'll come back on the show
to talk about that when brexit actually
happens it's good to see you thank you